*Sick noises*
Before this video begins
I have an important announcment :O
There's gonna be a new green-screen competition
Green screen competition No. 2 [The sequel]
Is happening *OMG*
All the info is down in the description
Basically I recorded myself with a green screen
I want you to edit
Me *nhnhn* and the most creative and funny edits
Will make it into a video that i react to
All the info is in the description, check it out
I can't wait to see what you make
This one is... *very* interesting
*Laughs*
Last week I played your games, they were *kisses fingers*
[Silence o.o]
Top quality memes [Aw thx pewds]
*Sucks finger* Tastes just like.. the finest potato [Jacksepticeye?]
Mwha
I'm so excited, we have three more games
Michael, who helps me out, he played through all of them
And he said this is the best one, so... ;)
*breaths*
*Winks* 0.o
We're gonna have to see
This game is called: Malcom1466's a-adventure
Please kill me right now
ahhhhh Let's go on an adventure with Malcom!
[complete silent]
I like the undertale music :)
"I'm too rich, I'm bored."
"What does rich men do when they are bored?" (bad grammar and german accent)
Yeah, what do they do Malcom?
What do they do?
"Shut up Jessica."
Ha ha ha (dissing his own girlfriend)
*breaths*
"Sometimes easy that pays well" [Great reading]
The fuck is it
"I know!"
*breaths*
"I will make videos on YouTube!"
*Mha*
"Choose a name for you YouTube channel"
"I didn't know making videos was that hard..."
HA!
*breaths*
"Well, my name is Malcom, and I was born in-"
*Laughs*
"In 1875 so I should name myself..."
Oh, my voice can't handle this
"Malcom1466!!"
"You are now entering YouTube world good luck"
*exclamation point*
"What the f-"
OHHHHH SHIITTT
Wait, he's literally entering YouTube world o.o
What the fuck, man
*minor explosion*
What, i'm playing as Malcom D:
Is this me?
"Is he sleeping?"
"Hey you! Wake up and tell me where i am"
I love the avatars they use for Malcom
"Hey... I'm Poodiepie"
"Did you ever shave?"
"If i don't wanna shave, i don't shave, you fat punk"
Jesus Christ!
"Don't call me fat"
"Because you're fat too" [BUUUUURRRN!!] [Less than you morbidly obese fuck]]
*Nice, calm music*
Poodiepie is attacking! o.o
*Nice music continues*
Pff,  the music.
*breaths*
I'm crying :'(
Let's fight him
Let's fight Pewdiepie
Pewdiepie used Brofist
Malcom took - Oh Jesus Christ
Malcom has lost :(
*rip malcom*
"I'm gonna destroy you" [BITCH!]
"NYEHEHEHEHE"
"What's that?" *Epic caw*
"It's me Pewdiepie"
"Sponsor Eagle!"
"Don't destroy the McDonald Boy"
*he ha ha*
"He probably is the new-"
I don't know the voice for Sponsor Eagle ):
*breaths*
"He probably is the new chosen one"
"No... He can't be..."
"Moreover, you're a terrible creature"
"Torturing such a poor, innocent youth" [innocent, we all know means "guilty"]
"You're right, i will not make the same mistakes"
"Thank you Sponsor Eagle"
Come with me...
*Epic caw*
"You've fallen into the YouTube World, a place where you can become famous and rich"
"But also be hated by everyone " ;(
This is very true
*phhh*
"I am the ruler of this world"
"Since i am the richest man of the overworld"
"Thanks to my channel and my billions of accounts ;D"
"But there is a prophecy;"
"One day a new king will fall down here"
"By becoming great on YouTube"
"In order to do that you will have to find and climb:"
*tense silence*
"The wall of dicks"
*laughs*
"I will come back to you when you reach the wall"
*Static sound*
Malcom...
*byeww*
Yha ha ha
*breaths*
Ayyy!
Wha-?
*ha ha*
Playing the song i made :)
Aw man, I miss this song...
Oh, i gotta climb it
*Y-huh*
"You shall not pass"
Come on Jennifer, get the fuck out of the way! >:(
"It is written:"
*...*
"I can't read"
*Laughs*
*breaths*
"That's my grave"
Who said that -_-
"Who is there?"
"Me! :)"
Oh, there's... haha
*breaths*
That's where potato fell
"Where are you?"
"That is not the most important"
"What you should know is that climbing the Wall..."
"...Is not the best way to become famous"
"You have to be sure that it's what you want, before going this way"
"Trust me, sucking dicks is tiring,"
"And can blow your mind if you're not prepared enough"
"I want more money, I am prepared"
"You seem to be filled with determination"
"You are ready to climb the wall of dicks ;)"
"Goodbye master"
"Jennifer, you can let him pass"
"If you see Poods, tell him that i love him <3"
"You can walk on me now"
"Ouch, you're fat"
"DON'T CALL ME FAT!"
*laughs*
"Goodbye..."
"See you soon..."
"Come back again..."
*breaths*
Ohh, we're CLIMBINGTHE WALL OF DICKS! :D
"Come on, you can do it"
This is amazing.
This is so good
This is beautiful, this game is true art
"The developer didn't want to put dicks in his game"
"This gate leads to the top of the wall"
"This game sucks!"
"I hate this game! >:("
Malcom, why are you always so upset, man?
Ayy! Ha ha
Love how there's a toilet there
"You made it to the top"
Yea!
"I knew there was something in you, kid"
"Now for the final test" :o
"Will you destory the world?"
I get to choose
I will go yes 'cause im Malcom [Great logic]
"Thanks to you i can retrieve my final form"
Jesus Christ!
"Now it's timke to destroy YouTube World"
"I'm just kidding, if i do that i will no longer have a job"
*Laughs*
"You told me i was gonna be king of YouTube"
"Give me the power and the money"
*dramatic music change*
"Did you really think is was gonna be that easy!"
"I am the ruler of the world, the king of YouTube"
"I am YouTube and YouTube is me!"
"I make more money in one video than you will ever"
"Hnng (?) In your entire life"
*breaths*
"And your fat ass will never be able to handle the pressure"
"Of being the king"
So fucking true!
This game spits the truth
Yea ^.^
"What about the prophecy?"
"You lied to me!"
"No, i never lied to you"
"All this time..."
*boom*
"It was just a prank bro!!" haha
*breaths*
"The camera is right there bro!"
Eyy the rh--
"I will make a lot of money with this video "
"You - You only work for the money"
"Now, go back where you came from"
"NOOOO!"
"AAHAHAHAHAHA!"
Ohh, my God
"I am back here"
"I am not the ruler of YouTube ):"
"Pewdiepie..."
I love the avatar it's so cute! <3
Malcom's so cute
"He only works for the money..."
"Pewdiepie SUCKS!"
*breaths*
"I HATE PEWDIEPIE!!" ha ha
*dying whale*
*older dying whale*
[(Song): It's just a prank, bro]
Ayyyyyyy
*Claps*
[It's just a prank]
[The camera is right there, bro]
Bravo!
Eranoth
[The camera is right there]
And, and thanks to Kiwiastic94
[It's just a prank]
And tutorialsByHugo
And of course for competition fo all the videos that made me laugh
[Don't you like pranks, bro]
If you are french go check out my channel Eranoth
[I guess you don't like pranks]
Lol, best ad ever
[I stole your car, just a prank bro]
Si vous etes francais, alles voir ma chaine Eratoth
Si vous etes francais, alles voir ma channel Eratoth
[I fucked your wife, just a prank bro]
[I gave you AIDS, just a prank bro]
Well fair enough, you made an awesome game
I appreciate that you did that
[I gave you AIDS, just a prank bro]
[I ruined your life, just a prank bro]
All that work
Really like it, it was really creative and original
[I ruined your life, just a prank bro]
[Can't just people understand that it's just a prank]
The backstory of Malcom,
And why he hates Pewdiepie
Now we know!
We got two more, let's check 'em out
This game is called: Pewds,
*Intense zoom*
Ze diamond button
Sounds interesting, let's play
*Brazilian Flower (song) starts*
Oh God, this fucking track
*Seizure dancing*
Uuaahhhh!
*More seizure dancing*
*hood falls down ):*
Let's do it!
*pimp music starts*
Playing 'Dramatic Hop hop Instrumental'
*puts on sungalsses aka swag*
Bess game
*Pimp music intestifies*
This is me! Haha
Why is my mustache so goddamn big?
Let's go in-
*locked*
Nevermind... ):
Let's go here-
*blocked*
Nevermind...
Let's go here-
Nevermind ;'(
Bess game
What the fuck?
"Where you think you're going?"
"No one just steps on out territory and leaves"
Oh my God!
"That's right ugly ass where yo ass think it going!"
"You came to the wrong neighbourhood mothafucka"
JESUS!
"Damn it! The notorious Duck Gang from Norway!"
"I though walking alone through a suspicious neighbourhood would have saved me from this possibility"
This is so well written *kisses hand*
I love it :)
"Wait... Why would i think that?"
"Dumb bitch!"
This feels a little...
Feels a little racist
"Yea, dumb bitch"
"Hey, that's my line!"
"B-B-B-BITCH!"
*ha ha ha*
"This cwacker fiesty"
"Yea, he fiesty"
"Shut up, Ramone"
This is definitely racist. What the fuck
"And you addicted to porn T-Tivan"
"Ey man, bread brumb porn is high quality entertainment!"
*Pewds is thinking*
Wait, is that a thing?
Oh, it's definitely a thing!
Well, rule 34
Pff, Jesus Christ!
"Tivan, shut this digga up"
"Ramone, we don't use that kind of language"
The fuck is going on?
"Especially to an old friend"
"Bob the duck, is that you?"
"Bob, you know this Swedish trash?"
"Yes... Me and him fought in the first Barrel War"
*face palm*
They've got a whole lore set up, apprently
"Hate to break up your shitty dialogue"
Yeah, no
"But if you are the Pewdiepie guy you must have a lot of money on your ass"
"Well we gon be taking it, right Trivan?"
"Let's duck him up Ramone!"
God damn it!
*slow zoom*
I'm, i'm so fucking sick of the bass line dude
Wait I died! D:
"Tivan, Ramone, what the hell guys he is a friend"
"Glory to Norway!"
FUCK NORWAY!
"Duck Sweden"
..Fuck Sweden
No, I don't.. I don't wanna go through all that again!
*Fast-forward*
Fuck yeah, i killed one of them!
Aw shit, i'm taking a lot of damage
YEAH!
FUCK YOU DUCKS!
FUCK YOU!
I TOLD YOU I'D FUCK YOU ONE DAY DUCKS!
YOU FUCKING DUCKS!
I FUCKED YOU!
I'D FUCK A DUCK! (Wtf man)
"Trivan, Ramone, what the hell guys he's a friend!
"Glory to Norway"
"Trivan..."
"Yeah Ramone?"
"I've always loved you..."
*claps*
I'm out
Great game,
Great game though *points*
*Sigh*
Why?
"Just leave before it gets weirder than it already is"
"I remember being forced to read a fanfic like this once before"
I do!
Alright, let's just go here
Ayyy!
"Well, we're here"
"Thanks Bob"
"I'll be off now. Goodbye Pewds and good luck"
See you on the other side Bob ;(
"What the hell is that, DMX?"
Great
Aw, Deadpool
There's so much copyright in one second there
My channel just had a seizure
"You can bet your sweaty balls it is"
"DEADPOO-"
"Ah, this game already has enough copyright-"
Oh my God that's what I said!
"So from now on i am Senoir Pool"
"One moment please"
"How the hell?"
"To be honest the game developer is just getting lazy"
"Well thanks, i'll be off now"
"I have a little bitch to catch"
"You do that, i'll just be running my store"
Wait, deadpool just became a fucking-
Store vendor?
"What can i get my favourite Swedish meatball?"
Stop calling me a Swedish meatball!
I'll have five swedish meatballs please
"Good luck and may the force be with you"
"Wait wrong reference"
"Where the hell is this? Is this supposed to be YouTube HQ?"
"Wait... This chair... This fan"
*dramatic music begins*
"No! No! I thought i was done after 4!"
*phone rings*
"I won't! Never again!"
*Laughs*
*breaths*
The plot twist!
It's FNAF five
"Hello, hello, hello?"
"Kaften!"
*Laughs*
"Oh come on Pewds"
"After my fourth official five nights at Freddy's game"
"Why wouldn't y- I keep making more"
"Think of all the money i make!"
"Believe it Pewdiepie. You are no longer King of YouTube"
"I AM"
"What do I do? These metal furries will wake up any moment"
"And tear my butthole open" o.o
"Felix..."
*really?*
Yes Neo?
"Who said that?"
It is I, Neo, from the Matrix"
"Oh hey, what's up"
"I came to tell you that none of this is real"
"Whatever do you mean?"
It is a game within your life within a game"
Or maybe a life within a game within a game or maybe..."
"Just get on with it!"
"I'm saying unlike starndard five nights-- FNAF"
"You can walk around and beat the animatronics"
"Now go Felix, the fate of YouTube is in your hands"
"Don't do meth kids, or cocaine"
"Wait"
"I keep an enitre Mexican drug cartel within my body"
What the.. what the fuck?
"Got any weed?"
I'm really questioning my life choices right no-
*great editing*
Let's swear
That's my special attack...
Swearing :3
Holy shit that was awesome!
-Swedish-
Ayyy
Red bull obtained :D
"Dine on my oven baked avian behind!"
Jesus, no!
"Gime that dick"
*hides*
(Faint) No!
Oh my God
*throws up a bit*
I did not need to see that [Agreed]
"Let me eat that booty like a cupcake"
Let's keep... Let's cut that bitch"
Fuck yeah! We got Chika
Ah, for fuck-
God!
Black Freddy, why not
"Suprise mothafucka"
"I find it extremely racist that each freddy is defined by its color alone"
"Your face is racist"
"Bitch!"
*puts on swag*
"BITCH!"
I'm starting to think this is a bad idea
"To let you bros have any form of control"
"Over my channel, and what i do"
"The Swedish meatball turns into an above average Swedish guy
Use it
I'm gonna have to pull out my Swedish meatball, my trump card
"AHHHHHHHHH"
What the fu- ha ha ha ha
*chokes*
Oh HELL YEAH!
Swedish meatball all the way!
Yea!
Get fucked Black Freddy
In no racist way, that's the developer
I obtain Omega Dildo by everyone
"I beat those three assholes, how many more are there?"
"Five nights worth"
Jesus
"Yeah, no"
"Wait, what?"
"So listen... Uh, I'm the guy working on this game"
"Honestly i'm a lazier developer than you, Scott"
*Laughs*
*breaths twice*
"So yeah, y-you two just figh it out"
"So i can wrap this game up and Felix can get the diamond play button" :D
"He'll have to win first"
"He will"
"Fuck you and your dumbass RPG maker game!"
"Fi-final Fantast VII music?"
"Please don't copyright me"
*ah*
Of course, Malcom
Of course Malcom, that son a a bitch
"Comes to the forwards Pewdiepie"
Oh no, not Malcom!
God damn it
"Fed Ex deliver guy you stole my button!"
"Oh... I still have on zis?"
"One of ze moments"
"Zer... Hellos Pewdiepie"
"MALCOM1466!!"
"He has finally arrives"
"Now i ams going to gets ze revenge"
"Revenge... For what?"
"Wells... Uh... I'm not thinked that far..."
*ha*
"Nah, more like the writers didn't think that far"
"Fuck you."
*laugh*
"But wait"
"So you did all this for nothing"
"What the fuck is the point of all this"
"Give me my god damn play button before i shove a sharp object up your rectum!"
"Zere is one problem with that"
"I don't have it anymores"
"I did ze throwing behind me"
Oh shit
Star Wars just started playing
Shit just got real
"What are you za doing?"
Oh
Ohh!
ZAHH!
*ha ha*
*breaths*
"I hate you! Pewdiepie sucks!"
"You were the chosen troll Malcom!"
"You were supposed to bring me"
"Ba-- My button"
"Anyways, so the game is finished, phew"
"I thought this shit excuse for a game was gonna go on another twenty minutes"
"Oh so that's how it is, eh?"
"Alright how about i'll add another final boss"
"Gimme a sec"
"And who's the boss supposed to be?"
"One cannot refer to me as "who", for that would dictate a singular being"
"I am the combination of the greatest minds in existence"
"I am..."
"The illuminati?" Δ
"What!? How.. did.."
"I was getting to, GAH"
Ah, fuck me, we're fighting the Illum- ...All Right
"I think it's time you handed YouTube to the next generation"
"And let them decide the best for it"
"Dull until the last moment, goodbye my one true love"
We're fighting the Illuminati Δ, Okay great
Um... I guess i'll just swear
The fuck is this soundtrack? o.o
Fuck i should have stocked up on meatballs
Do i have anymore?
God damn it, i'm fucked
Alright, we got this
Here we go...
*Cha!*
Ayyy
"Felix was victorious"
WOO!
"How... This is impossible"
"Well i mean not reall, it is a game afterall"
"Just finish me off..."
"Gladly!"
"Wait, don't actually"
What?
What is happening? D:
My diamond play button!
"Shit, shit"
"Shit, well it's just-"
"It's just you.." Wait 0.o
"Well it's just me and you my diamond friend"
"I'll see you in afterlife"
Oh my God
"Ah"
"It's 4pm I gotta get a video out"
*laugh*
*breaths*
Ah, man
"*Turns on camera*"
"Ok don't fuck it up like yesterday's intro"
What the hell, man?
"How's it going bros, my name is Pewdiepie"
"-PEWDIEPIE-"
"And t-" I did fuck it up ):
"And today i have something spe-"
"God damn it, i'm coming"
"Kaften, i'm coming"
"Well good job you got through this beautiful piece of shit i call a game"
"Hope you weren't too bored"
*drops headphones*
*takes of jumper very sexily*
*fixes hair*
Alright it was a bit long
But I enjoyed it :)
*laugh*
Tha's like legit of a game
I told- I told like
Don't make it too complicated
And it seems like people really took it far
And i appreciate that, it was really cool
Thank you this beautiful, beautiful being for making this game
*kisses*
*you are now blessed*
Bros
I am so proud of you for making these games
I'm so happy i have suck awesome fans
Who create funny, and original, and crazy shit like this
I love that. So thanks you so much if you watch this
I- thanks to everyone who was participating in this
Even if I didn't play your game I really really appreciate all the work and effort
That you bros spend around whatever it is I do here online
It's amazing and i'm so humbled by it
Thank you <3
*sigh*
Don't forget to leave a like if you enjoyed this video
I get more likes that way
And as always, Brofist